Jonathan Abram well people like to talk
trash like your teammates and later so I
go Raiders fans get out of there for
someone else I grew for someone has a
chance oh so wrong too much
oh are you Duncan Aron
what up everybody let's go out here in
Oakland we're meeting up with Raiders
rookie Johnathan Abram I want you to be
the best teammate in the history of the
NFL we're gonna surprise some
unsuspecting fans they think we're doing
a documentary about being a non Raiders
fan and open so you're a Raiders fan
they're gonna talk trash about his
teammates and we'll see if he defends
them and let's be honest being surprised
by an NFL player it's a good surprise
what we don't want surprises in is in
our home and auto insurance all we want
is good reliable quality coverage like
the kind you get from state fun and all
right all right let's go let's take you
deep squad you ready all right
the ultimate teammate this time all
right senior position what do you think
of Raiders fans hmm they could be better
man Raiders fans they're loyal fans but
they're blind like get out of there root
for someone else like root for someone
who has a chance you know and that's
coming from a Jets fan you're a comedian
were in Oakland up oh look at this
can I get your Raiders set I was doing
jokes and Sebastian Janikowski was
actually in the audience he picked up
his drink and he threw it at me then I
remembered he was the kicker for the
Oakland Raiders for 20 years
does the drink was coming towards me I
just went like this
and that drink sailed 30 yards to the
right miss me mr. stage was everybody
completely I'm a free agent fan now
I was a lifelong Raider fence December
2017 was my divorce what happened
Derek Carr fumbled the ball out the end
zone they trade it my favorite player
Khalil Mack they gave Ruth 100 million
dollars Jeong Ruby
Chucky dumb at all times like you know
like Derek Carr like I mean what is he
you know are you excited for me bozo
did you not see it minute Hogan well
this is true you do throw people around
for a fee so he playing football Mark
Sanchez when he came I was excited about
that you know yeah I go he fumble of his
own lineman boy Michael Crabtree he got
mad him it's a true story at Tommy T is
the local comedy club here I wanted to
shake his hand later and he missed me
completely just like how you miss
snapping off his route every single time
probably Dan Marino yeah when was it I
think I don't think you were born listen
that Miami Dolphins have been mediocre
for a very long time so how can you root
for this because they're at least
mediocre the Oakland Raiders are one
four and twelve season away from putting
up and put an eye patch on the other eye
you over saying what I'm saying
so the last time the Raiders went to a
single AFC Championship game and wait
what do you think about Jonathan a bro
do a heavy hitter but you can't
pronounce this sign it seared salmon or
seared salmon salmon salmon salmon would
you say that to his face
oh yeah I'm gonna be like this I'm not a
football player I used to be in a club
with Charles Woodson tweet Jimmy's and
and Jefferies and everything we know
where it's two for now yeah the
youngster a brush is a banging out there
[Laughter]
listen I'm gonna tell you like this this
gives you a big football player from
Mississippi don't mean you can't
mispronounce a word good boy
are you Jonathan Aron wait what oh man I
think he loves you man oh you looking
out man I remember you from Hard Knocks
always talking oh wow I ain't a lot of
things like when I ready to play the
Dolphins I'd be like cuz I'm ready I'd
be like oh that's a win you watch the
game
yeah well you know sometimes somebody's
going 12 record I always know y'all
gonna be one of the wins makes me think
it's like Mississippi State all over
again or something like that you know I
mean the state yeah Mississippi State
it's a good junior college football
program good junior college
I'm not playing at all I think they're
very very good who made the English
language
Oh mein English language who may English
as I said tomato tomahto
are we gonna come to the next game
dressed in silver and black if you give
me tickets our Jersey may be there you
serious we just do a bigger deal
switched fan allegiance it's happening
yeah we a badger nation just grew by one
skir the Dolphins Sweden who needs a
dolphin win baby yeah I think that all
if we ever see you with that god-awful
orange and green on y'all ready what is
he's a raid
we're here to bring you back so the
writers I'm back I'm just letting you
know like we're gonna take out you know
how you get on the flight maybe like the
board belleros in ten minutes
yeah be it exposes you got you ain't got
much loan to get on the plane
I got y'all I got so what do you mean I
gotcha
yeah the today was a successful day I
think we proved to everybody that you
are the best teammate effort nobody
could talk trash in your team grew
Raider Nation by three got three new
fans back in the fold a one by one baby
week we gettin bit you got something to
say about the bridges just be where we
might be hiding the euro what this is
Josh Norman on the Washington Redskins
subscribe to bleacher report on YouTube
for more deuce to playbook